I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who are there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello everybody. Hi.
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。大家好。嗨。
Are you ready for this week's episode, Missus California? I am. I enjoy this episode so much. I found myself laughing really hard. I thought Ed Helms as Andy being caught between Mr. and Mrs. California was, his performance was amazing. Well, this is season eight, episode nine. It was written by new writer,
加州太太，你准备好迎接收看本周的节目了吗？我准备好了。我很喜欢这一集。我发现自己笑得非常厉害。我认为埃德·赫尔姆斯饰演的安迪夹在加州先生和加州太太之间，他的表现简直太棒了。嗯，这是第八季第九集。它是由新编剧，
alert Dan Greeney. He had previously worked on the Simpsons. This was his first office script, and it was directed by Charlie Grandy. Who I got to talk to about this episode. And I've got some really fun information to share. Oh, I love Charlie. He was so fun to have one set. He was great. Here is your summary. And he is confused when Robert California charges him with the task of finding a job for his wife, Susan,
注意，丹·格里尼（Dan Greeney）编写的。他以前曾在《辛普森一家》工作过。这是他的第一部《办公室》剧本，由查理·格兰迪（Charlie Grandy）导演。我有幸跟他聊过这一集。而且我有一些非常有趣的信息要分享。哦，我喜欢查理。他在片场时太有趣了。他太棒了。这是你的剧情摘要。他感到很困惑，因为罗伯特·加州交给他的任务是为他的妻子苏珊找一份工作，
while simultaneously insisting she not work there under any circumstances. Meanwhile, Dwight opens a gym in the building and coaches his reluctant first member, Darryl. Fast fact number one, Moratirney as Mrs. California. Is she the coolest or what? She is the coolest lady. I just remember having a girl crush on her
同时又坚决坚持在任何情况下她都不能在那里工作。与此同时，德怀特在楼里开了一家健身房，并指导他勉强加入的第一位会员达里尔。冷知识第一条：莫拉·蒂尔尼（Maura Tierney）饰演加州太太。她是不是最酷的人？她绝对是最酷的女士。我只记得当时对她有少女崇拜，
and really wanting her to like me so much so when you see her over and accounting, do you see me just like laughing like, hi, you're so cool. For years, my agents would pitch me as a moratirney type. Really? Because she did whose radio. And they were like, that would be a perfect role for you,
非常希望她能喜欢我，所以当你看到她在会计部时，你会看到我就像在大笑一样：嗨，你太酷了。多年来，我的经纪人一直把我当成莫拉·蒂尔尼那种类型的人来推销。真的吗？因为她演过《新闻广播员》。他们说，对你来说这将是一个完美的角色，
Jenna, we're gonna pitch you as a moratirney type. I was so bummed out that I did not get to work with her in this episode. I think we should play sisters, personally. Oh, you so should. Right? Yes. I know, I love her. She's cooler than me. Oh, you so sure. Right? Yes. I know, I love her.
珍娜，我们会把你推销为莫拉·蒂尔尼那种类型的。我非常沮丧，因为我没能在这集里和她一起合作。就我个人而言，我觉得我们应该扮演姐妹。哦，你们真的应该。对吧？是的。我知道，我很喜欢她。她比我酷。哦，你们真的应该。对吧？是的。我知道，我很喜欢她。
She's cooler than me. She would be my cool older sister. Exactly. Right, that we want to hang out with. Yeah. Yeah. Well, we got a lot of fan questions about Mora, particularly from Kitty G and Austin, Texas, who said,
她比我酷。她会是我酷酷的姐姐。完全正确。对吧，就是那种我们想和她一起出去玩的人。耶。耶。好吧，我们收到了很多关于莫拉的粉丝提问，特别是来自德克萨斯州奥斯汀的基蒂·G，她说，
I was so excited to see one of my all-time favorite actresses, Mora Terni, pop up as Mrs. California. How did she end up on the show? Well, Charlie Grandy said that Paul Lieberstein really wanted Moratirni and everybody else was instantly on board. Charlie said in addition to being funny, she had a really natural warmth and strength, which was key in this episode. Well, like I said, I'm bummed I couldn't be there. Maybe one day, there's a project in store for me and Mora. I would watch that. We need to get on it. She could be a mom detective, you know. We need a mom detective like, we need our boss, our boss. Oh, the boss of the mom person. The person we call in to. Yes. Yes. She's it. Mara, we have a job for you.
我很高兴看到我一直以来最喜欢的女演员之一莫拉·蒂尔尼客串加州太太。她是怎么加入这部剧的？嗯，查理·格兰迪说保罗·利伯斯坦非常想要莫拉·蒂尔尼，其他所有人都立刻赞同了。查理说，除了搞笑之外，她身上有一种非常自然的亲和力和力量感，这在这集中是关键。嗯，就像我说的，我很沮丧我不能去。也许有一天，会有我和莫拉合作的项目。我会看的。我们得抓紧了。她可以演个妈妈侦探，你知道的。我们需要一个妈妈侦探，就像我们需要我们的老板，我们的老板。哦，妈妈本人的老板。我们去求助的那个人。对。对。就是她。玛拉，我们有个工作要给你。
Done. All right. Are you ready for fast fact number two? This is a fan question from Kate Kaye in Holland, Michigan, who says, not so much a question, but rather a feminist rant. Okay, I hate that Robert introduces his wife to the bullpen as Mrs. Robert, California, so, so much. She corrects them immediately by asking to be called Susan, but this demonstrates an epidemic
搞定。好的。你们准备好迎接冷知识第二条了吗？这是一个来自密歇根州荷兰镇的凯特·K的粉丝提问，她说，与其说是一个问题，不如说是一次女权主义的咆哮。好吧，我讨厌罗伯特把他的妻子介绍给开放式办公室时称她为罗伯特·加州太太，太讨厌了。她马上纠正了他们，要求叫她苏珊，但这表现出了一种普遍现象，
that I am so repulsed by. Why is it always Mr. and Mrs. the man's last name? I feel like there's a deep dive here, just waiting to be unpacked and rant it about. Hashtag down with the patriarchy. Kate, I like your fire. I'm liking it. Mm-hmm.
让我感到非常反感。为什么总是先生和太太，冠以男人的姓氏？我觉得这里面有一个等待被剖析和吐槽的深度探讨。话题：打倒父权制。凯特，我喜欢你的这股火辣劲。我挺你。嗯哼。
I deep-dived it for you, and here you go. Okay. Women did not always take their husbands last name. In fact, last names didn't even matter at first, because back in the dark ages, I guess populations were so small that you just went by your first name. But later, when last names mattered, that's when women started taking the last name of their husbands.
我为你做了一番深度探讨，给你这个。好吧。女性并不总是随丈夫的姓。事实上，一开始姓氏甚至并不重要，因为回到黑暗时代，我想人口太少，你们直接叫名就可以了。但后来，当姓氏变得重要时，女性才开始随丈夫的姓。
And according to several articles, including one from brides.com, the reason is because women did not hold any legal rights on their own. They couldn't own land. That's right. That's right. Yes. Or if you were injured as a woman, and someone was to be compensated for your injury, it was either your father because you were his property or your husband once you married. Women could not enter into contracts, however, they could be employed, but their husband collected their wages. Also, the husband held the right to sexual access to their wife. So this was all, you know, back in the day. Kind of sounds like the handmaid's tail. Oh, of sounds like the handmaid's tale.
根据几篇文章，包括来自brides.com的一篇文章，原因是因为女性本身不享有任何法律权利。她们不能拥有土地。没错。没错。是的。或者，如果你作为一个女性受到伤害，有人要对你的伤害进行赔偿，那要么是你的父亲，因为你是他的财产，要么是你结婚后的丈夫。女性不能签订合同，然而，她们可以被雇用，但她们的丈夫会收走她们的工资。此外，丈夫拥有与妻子发生性关系的权利。所以这些都是，你知道的，过去的事。听起来有点像《使女的故事》。哦，听起来很像《使女的故事》。
Oh, a lot like the handmaid's tale. One of the first things that happens when they're slowly taking over is that they close all the women's banking accounts and have their funds transferred to their husband's accounts. Yeah. Creepy stuff. Right. Here's something I found out. Did you know that prior to the 1970s, there were laws in the United States that said,
哦，真的很像《使女的故事》。当他们慢慢接管时，发生的第一件事就是关闭所有女性的银行账户，并将她们的资金转移到丈夫的账户中。是的。毛骨悚然的东西。对。这是我发现的一件事。你知道吗，在20世纪70年代之前，美国有这样的法律：
women could not get a driver's license, a passport, or registered a vote, unless a woman took her husband's last name. If you were unmarried, you could. But if you were married, you could only do those things if you took your husband's last name. Hmm. It was the Supreme Court case of Don versus Palermo that struck down a Tennessee law that required women to take their husband's last name in order to vote, and that is when it finally ended. And that is also when the little, what do you call
除非女性随丈夫的姓，否则女性不能获得驾照、护照或登记投票。如果你未婚，你可以。但如果你已婚，只有随丈夫的姓，你才能做那些事情。嗯。正是唐诉帕勒莫（Don v. Palermo）最高法院案件推翻了一项田纳西州的法律，该法律要求女性为了投票而必须随丈夫的姓，这才是它最终结束的时候。这也是那个，你叫什么来的？
it? The prefix, Miz came into play. Because you could be a miss, a miss or a miss. Wanna hear about a bad-ass lady? Yeah. Amelia Earhart. She refused to go by her husband's last name. And after her first solo trans-Atlantic flight, the New York Times wrote a big article about her and the whole time they were furged to her as Mrs. Putnam.
前缀“Miz”开始出现的时候。因为你可以是Miss、Miss或Miss。想听听关于一个女中豪杰的故事吗？想。阿 Amelia Earhart（阿梅莉亚·埃尔哈特）。她拒绝随她丈夫的姓。在她完成第一次单人横跨大西洋的飞行后，《纽约时报》写了一篇关于她的大文章，在整篇文章中他们都称她为普特南太太。
So she wrote them a letter. Yes, she did. She said, as previously stated. I mean, we all know if someone says that, they're like, listen, this is my polite way of saying go F yourself. Yes, I will say that phrase was not in her letter, but it was implied. She did say like, as stated in my previous letters to you, I would like you to refer to me by my professional name,
所以她给他们写了一封信。是的，她写了。她说，如前所述。我的意思是，我们都知道如果有人这么说，他们其实是在说：听着，这是我礼貌地对你说“去你妈的”的方式。是的，我要说的是这个词不在她的信里，但它是言下之意。她确实说过，正如我在之前的信中所述，我希望你们用我的职业名字来称呼我，
Amelia Earhart, and not Mrs. Putnam. Yeah. So I took my husband's last name. I am Jenna Kirk. I took his last name and approximately 70% of women still take their husband's last names when they get married. 20% keep their maiden names and 10% hyphenate their name or they make up a new name, a new last name together.
阿梅莉亚·埃尔哈特，而不是普特南太太。是的。所以我随了我丈夫的姓。我是珍娜·柯克。我随了他的姓，大约70%的女性在结婚时仍然随丈夫的姓。20%的人保留娘家姓，10%的人使用连字符连接姓氏，或者他们一起创造一个新名字、一个新姓氏。
I'm in the 20%. Okay. I did not take my husband's last name. I am just Angela Kinsey. Although I absolutely love being Josh's wife, I am the last of four girls. And I remember when my dad was alive telling him, dad, I'll keep the Kinsey for ya. Oh, that's so sweet.
我属于那20%。好吧。我没有随我丈夫的姓。我就是安吉拉·金西。虽然我非常喜欢做乔什的妻子，但我家里有四个女孩，我是老幺。我记得在我爸爸还活着的时候告诉他，爸爸，我会为你保留金西这个姓。哦，太甜了。
So his name would live on at least a little longer through me, right? Yeah, yeah. And it meant a lot to him. So that was something I wanted to do for my dad. I love that lady. Yeah, and Josh doesn't mind at all. He knows I'm also Mrs. Snyder.
这样他的名字至少还能通过我多延续一会儿，对吧？对，对。这对意义重大。所以这是我想为我爸爸做的事。我喜欢这个女人。是的，乔什一点也不介意。他知道我也是斯奈德太太。
Well, you know, very occasionally, men will take their wives' last names, but it is much more difficult to do it. Like, when a woman gets married on your marriage certificate, there's just a line where you can fill in. That line isn't there for the men, I guess, because only in Georgia, Hawaii, Iowa, Massachusetts, New York, and North Dakota, is it is easy for a man to take his wife's last name upon marriage as the other way around.
嗯，你知道，极少数情况下，男性会随他们妻子的姓，但要做到这一点要困难得多。比如，当一个女人结婚时，在你的结婚证书上只有一行你可以填写的空白。这行空白对男人来说是不存在的，我想，因为只有在佐治亚州、夏威夷州、爱荷华州、马萨诸塞州、纽约州和北达科他州，男人在结婚时随妻子的姓才和反过来一样容易。
So there's my deep dive for you, Kate. Well, I loved it. And right here in this room, the two of us represent two different sides. We do. Yeah. Ultimately, how I feel about it is, whatever is comfortable between you and your partner, ain't nobody else's business. Yeah. Yeah.
所以这就是我为你做的深度探讨，凯特。好吧，我很喜欢。而且就在这个房间里，我们两个代表了两个不同的立场。确实。是的。归根结底，我对这件事的看法是，只要你和你的伴侣感到舒服，其他任何人都不关事。对。对。
I like being Jenna Kirk. Yeah. All right. Are you ready, everybody? Yeah. For FastFak number three. Oh, yes. Yes, I forgot we were doing this.
我喜欢当珍娜·柯克。对。好了，大家准备好了吗？准备好了。为了冷知识第三条。哦，对了。是的，我忘了我们在做这个。
Yes. Alright, it is... Mom detectives and the case of the windowless building. Yes, our very first case! We drove to the windowless building. We sure did. Jenna got out her phone and recorded the audio of our whole investigation.
好的，它是……妈妈侦探与无窗建筑之谜。是的，我们的第一个案件！我们开车去了那栋无窗的建筑。我们当然去了。珍娜拿出了她的手机，录下了我们整个调查过程的音频。
Here it is. It was a cold and rainy night when someone dropped that package through my mailbox. So many clues, so much chaos. It had been a long time since I saw this big of a mess. But because it wasn't a far drive, and because it wasn't a school night, and because there was only a little bit of evidence so I could fit in a small amount of pockets, and because I had snacks in case they got hungry, and because it wasn't chilly out, God helped me, I knew who I needed to call. The Mom Detectives. Okay, here we go. Do you see it? Anjolicy, those are not windows. Oh, oh, there's a driveway. There's still people sitting outside. Oh, we got to go through the driveway. Let's go through the driveway.
录音在这里。那是一个寒冷多雨的夜晚，有人把那个包裹投进我的邮箱。如此多的线索，如此多的混乱。我已经很久没有见过这么大的烂摊子了。但因为开车不远，而且不是上学夜，而且只有一点点证据，我可以把它们塞进一小口袋里，而且因为我带了零食以防他们饿了，而且因为外面不是很冷，上帝保佑我，我知道我该打电话给谁。妈妈侦探。好的，我们走吧。看到了吗？安吉莉西，那些不是窗户。哦，哦，有个车道。外面还坐着人。哦，我们得穿过车道。我们穿过车道吧。
Okay, let's go in. What? Park right here. No, it's super free here. Yes, okay. It's working. Two hour working. I'm two-way away from the curve. What do you think? I'm not an eye fool. It's not unfixable. Let me back up. Just make up.
好吧，我们进去吧。什么？把车停在这。不，这里超级空。是的，好吧。管用。两小时工作制。我离路边还有两个车位远。你觉得呢？我又不是白痴。这也不是不能解决。我倒车。倒车。
Backing out. Now you're too close to the curve. I just occur. Okay. Okay. All right, let's get out. None of this is Windows. Okay. No, there's no Windows, but it looks like Windows. But it's also like CMAT, right? And also there's two numbers on the building.
往后退。现在你离路边太近了。我刚靠近。好的。好的。好吧，我们下车吧。这些都不是窗户。好吧。不，没有窗户，但它看起来像窗户。但它也像水泥厂，对吧？而且大楼上有两个号码。
I know it's a long address. I have to point out. But there's no trouble. There's like just a dirt patch. They just let it go. Good observation. Thank you. All right, we're walking in. We're currently walking in. The gate is open. The parking garage, there are no cars.
我知道地址很长。我得指出来。但没有什么麻烦。就像只有一小块泥地。他们就任由它荒着。观察得很好。谢谢。好了，我们走进去。我们现在正走进去。大门开着。停车场里没有车。
The pedestrian gate is locked, but there's one car. Oh my God, there's three sheds. There's three sheds, and there's four people and outside. Like the water, like the sensor thing? Wait, what are we doing? There's three sheds. There's three sheds. There's four people. And outside. The water, like the stints are saying? Wait, what are we doing? I'm just going to walk in and ask what the business is.
行人门锁着，但有一辆车。天哪，有三个棚子。有三个棚子，外面有四个人。就像水，像感应器那样的东西？等等，我们在干什么？有三个棚子。有三个棚子。有四个人。外面。水，就像感应器那样的东西？等等，我们在干什么？我这就走进去问问这是什么生意。
Okay, okay. Oh my gosh. I'm hanging back and digging back. She was walking in. Hey, we were just curious, what is this business? Talking to someone, it looks like a nurse. It looks like a very nice, young male nurse. Huh.
好吧，好吧。哦，天哪。我留在后面，退回后面。她正走进去。嘿，我们只是好奇，这是做什么生意的？正跟某个人说话，看起来像个护士。看起来像个非常好的年轻男护士。哼。
It's a daycare center for elderly people. It's open for four hours a day. They get two meals, and that's it. Well, that was anti-climactic. The Mom Detectives. Case solved in the most unthreatening, like, zero conspiracy. Like, really, the hype we gave this, and it's a senior citizen activity center. The thing is, why no name on the building, you know?
这是一个老年人日间护理中心。一天开门四个小时。他们提供两餐，就这样。好吧，这真是虎头蛇尾。妈妈侦探。以最无威胁感的方式破案，零阴谋。真的，我们把这事炒作得这么高，结果它是个老年人活动中心。问题是，为什么大楼上没有名字，你知道吗？
Like, just, it would be so easy. Do they not want you to know? Is it, I mean, wouldn't you put a sign like it's a beautiful facility? I walked in and it's so tonight. I walked in and I hung behind you a little, but I did look around. It had a little lobby area. Yes, and just a beautiful dining room. And something that nurse said was, they also do occupational therapy
就像，这太容易了。难道他们不想让你知道？我是说，难道你不该挂个牌子说明它是一个漂亮的设施吗？我走进去，里面太温馨了。我走进去，落在你后面一点，但我确实环顾四周。它有一个小大厅区域。是的，还有一个漂亮的餐厅。那个护士说的一件事是，他们还在那里做职业疗法
and physical therapy there. I mean, so you don't want a sign that says what you are with a phone number so you can, someone can check it out. I thought it was odd. But, you know what, fine, mystery solved. Turns out the lack of shrubbery and three sheds. Angela, I thought you were very good at pointing out clues,
和物理疗法。我的意思是，难道你不想挂个牌子说明你们是什么并带个电话号码，好让人家来看看吗？我觉得这很奇怪。但是，你知道吗，好吧，谜团解开了。原来是缺乏灌木丛和三个棚子。安吉拉，我觉得你很擅长指出线索，
none of which led to the answer, none and all. But what if I had gone inside and they were evasive? We might have had to follow those leads, yeah. Mm. Well, you know, I have to say, I'll never forget the look on everyone's face when we did enter in the building. Yes. They were confused. I want to say that I gave no context when I walked in the building. None. I didn't say, hey, I watched this building be built and I'm just so curious, what is it?
但没有一个线索指向答案，全都没有。但如果我当时进去了，而他们态度闪烁其词呢？我们可能就得顺着那些线索追查下去，是的。嗯。好吧，你知道，我不得不说，我永远不会忘记我们走进大楼时每个人的表情。是的。他们很困惑。我想说的是，我走进大楼时没有任何前情提要。一点也没有。我没有说，嘿，我看着这栋楼建起来的，我很好奇，这是什么？
Yeah. I walked in and the guy said, can I help you? And I said, yes, what is this? Yeah. What is this facility? I said, can I help you? And I said, yes, what is this? Yeah. What is this facility? Mm-hmm. Yeah. I mean, I was very to the point.
是的。我走进去，那家伙说，有什么需要我帮忙的吗？我说，是的，这是什么？是的。这是什么设施？我说，有什么需要我帮忙的吗？我说，是的，这是什么？是的。这是什么设施？嗯哼。是的。我的意思是，我非常直奔主题。
I think maybe I need to work on my bedside manner as a detective. While you were doing that, an elderly man pointed at me and then talked to someone else and then that other person pointed at me. And so I just said, hi, how's it going? Yeah. I think they didn't know why I was there. We were there because we had a mystery to solve. That's right. I should have just said to them. I should have said, I'm sorry to disturb you, elderly fella. I am a mom detective. Yes, and I am
我想我可能需要改善一下我作为侦探的 bedside manner（病床边的礼貌/待人态度）。就在你这么做的时候，一个老头指着我，然后跟另一个人说话，接着那个人又指着我。所以我只好说，嗨，最近怎么样？是的。我想他们不知道我为什么在那儿。我们在那儿是因为我们有一个谜团要解开。没错。我当时应该直接对他们说。我应该说，对不起打扰了，老人家。我是一个妈妈侦探。是的，而且我是
here on a mission, but I am too embarrassed to walk all the way in, but my friend charged in there. So now I'm hanging on this patio with you. That's what's happening. Can I just say that I think some of my Hutzpah from the award show circuit is paying off as a mom detective? It's showed up. Yeah, perhaps they should have walked
带着任务来的，但我太尴尬了不敢一直走进去，不过我的朋友冲进去了。所以我现在只好和你们一起挂在这个天井里。事情就是这样。我能说我觉得我从红毯走秀学到的一些气势在作为妈妈侦探时派上用场了吗？它展现出来了。是的，也许他们应该
in the door laughing. No, and he would have laughed together. No, I think you made the right move to not walk in laughing. All right. Well, maybe we need outfits Because that would make it clearer hats who we are get his hats. Okay, they'll say MD I don't know Well, everyone there you go. That's what I got for fast facts. Should we take a break and then we'll come back and watch Dwight stand for a really long time? Yes.
笑着走进大门。不，然后他就会一起笑。不，我觉得你没有笑着走进去，这是对的做法。好吧。好吧，也许我们需要制服，因为那会更清楚地表明我们是谁，戴上帽子。好吧，它们会写着“MD”（妈妈侦探），我不知道。好吧，各位，这就是我准备的冷知识。我们要不要休息一下，然后回来观看德怀特站了很长很长时间？好的。
We are back and Dwight is standing at his desk and it's not just because he's standing hanging out at his regular desk. He has a new standing desk and he's looking over at Jim and he says, you know what, your hair's standing. Yeah, he explains that standing is healthier and more productive. So that's what he's going to do now. My husband has a standing desk. I was going to bring that up. Yes. I want you guys to know at one point, we were sharing a small room in our house and we made it into a little makeshift office.
我们回来了，德怀特正站在他的办公桌旁，这不仅仅是因为他在他常规的办公桌旁闲站着。他换了一个新的站立式办公桌，他正看着吉姆说，你知道吗，你的头发都竖起来了。是的，他解释说站着更健康、更高效。所以这就是他现在要做的。我丈夫有一个站立式办公桌。我正要提这个。是的。我想让你们知道，曾经有一段时间，我们在家里共用一个小房间，我们把它改造成了一个简易办公室。
It was that catch-all room. Mm-hmm. And he moved in his standing desk and I had my little lower desk. And it was like he was mission control, looming over me. And I was like, Bay, we have got to sort this out. You need your own place to stand and work because you're driving me crazy.
那是那个杂物间。嗯哼。他把他的站立式办公桌搬了进去，我有了我的低矮小书桌。这感觉就像他是任务控制中心，居高临下地笼罩着我。我说，宝贝，我们得把这个解决掉。你需要你自己的地方去站着工作，因为你快把我逼疯了。
But he loves his standing desk. He still has a standing desk. It's from Veridesk, shout out to those guys because he loves it. Well, I have a fan observation to kick off this episode from Charlotte E in the UK who would like to know, why does Kathy have Pam's baby photos of Cece on her desk after she's taken over on maternity leave? Surely she's gonna be there long enough to put up her own photos if she wants to. Charlotte, no. As Pam, my baby pictures are staying where they are. Kathy, don't you touch them.
但他很喜欢他的站立式办公桌。他现在仍然有一个站立式办公桌。它来自Veridesk，向他们致敬，因为他太喜欢了。好吧，我有一个粉丝观察要开启这一集，来自英国的夏洛特·E，她想知道，为什么凯蒂接替产假后，她的桌上有帕姆的宝宝塞西的照片？她在那里的时间肯定足够长，如果她愿意，可以摆上她自己的照片。夏洛特，才不呢。作为帕姆，我的宝宝照片会留在原地。凯蒂，你别碰它们。
I have a question. What? We've learned in this episode that Andy's desk is empty. Why can't Kathy just go sit there? I thought that a long time ago. Mm-hmm. I thought that during Pam's replacement because she does sit there a few times.
我有一个问题。什么？我们在这一集里了解到安迪的桌子是空的。为什么凯蒂不能去那儿坐？我很久以前就这么想过。嗯哼。我在帕姆找人代班期间就这么想过，因为她的确去那儿坐过几次。
There's no computer there right now. Well, you know what, sort it out and leave Pam's desk alone. You know? Don't even sit at Pam's desk. You know who's dropped that is. The office administrator. She should learn to take care of herself. We also had a fan catch from Elizabeth M.
那儿现在没有电脑。好吧，你知道吗，自己解决去，别动帕姆的桌子。你知道吗？甚至都别坐在帕姆的桌子旁。你知道那是谁的桌子吗。办公室管理员。她应该学会照顾自己。我们还收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州兰caster的伊丽莎白·M的粉丝抓包，
in Lancaster, Pennsylvania, who points out that Dwight has a mug with a sheet's logo on it. Elizabeth said, I love the detail work done by the props department. Little details like this make all the difference. I agree. Jim is going to see an opportunity here at Frank Dwight. He's going to say, you know what, Dwight, you're right. You're better than the rest of us. I'm proud of you. You're committing to standing and you're never going to sit again. You're going to stand forever, aren't you? And Dwight's like, yeah, I am. And almost immediately his ankle started bothering him. Yes, and he tries to sneak away to the break room to sit down,
她指出德怀特有一个印有Wawa（雪茨便利店）标志的杯子。伊丽莎白说，我喜欢道具部门做出的细节工作。这样的小细节让一切变得不同。我同意。吉姆在这里看到了一个捉弄德怀特的契机。他会说，你知道吗，德怀特，你是对的。你比我们所有人都好。我为你骄傲。你致力于站立，而且你再也不打算坐下了。你要永远站下去，对不对？德怀特就像，对，我是。几乎立刻他的脚踝就开始隐隐作痛。是的，他试图偷偷溜到休息室坐下来，
but then Darryl walks in to get some coffee, and I have something to say. About what? I need to discuss the coffee situation at Dundermifflin. Okay. There's a coffee maker in the kitchen. Right, why are people walking past it to go all the way to the break room? Thank you.
但接着达里尔走进来拿咖啡，我有话要说。关于什么？我需要讨论一下邓德米夫林的咖啡情况。好吧。厨房里有一个咖啡机。对，为什么人们要走过它一直走到休息室去？谢谢。
Now, something I did notice is that in the break room, there appears to be a decaf coffee option and a regular coffee option. In the kitchen, there is only regular coffee that Darrell gets regular coffee. He doesn't grab the decaf. Also, there is an entire coffee machine in the break room. One of the vending machines is all coffee.
现在，我注意到的一件事是，在休息室里，似乎有一个低因咖啡选项和一个常规咖啡选项。在厨房里，只有达里尔拿的常规咖啡。他没有拿低因咖啡。此外，休息室里还有一整台咖啡机。其中一台自动贩卖机全是咖啡。
And we have caffeine corner. We have a lot of coffee. There's like free coffee, vending machines is all coffee. And we have caffeine corner. We have a lot of coffee. There's like free coffee, vending machine coffee, I guess artisanal coffee. It's a lot of coffee. That's it, I needed to say it. For once. For once.
我们还有咖啡角。我们有很多咖啡。有免费咖啡，自动贩卖机咖啡，我猜还有手冲咖啡。咖啡太多了。就是这样，我不得不说出来。破天荒头一次。破天荒。
Season eight. I'm calling out this coffee bullshit that we've all had to live through. Thank you. It's been a long time. Well Dwight is back at his desk and he seems to be a lot chipper. He's humming. He's being nice to people. That's right. Jim approaches and notices something sticking out of Dwight's pants leg. It looks like some kind of, I don't know, pogo stick, what is it? Well, we had a fan question from KCB
第八季。我要痛斥这咖啡的狗屎情况，我们所有人都得忍受这些。谢谢。这已经持续很久了。好吧，德怀特回到了他的办公桌旁，他看起来精神焕发了许多。他在哼着歌。他对人也变好了。没错。吉姆走近并注意到有什么东西从德怀特的裤腿里伸出来。那看起来像某种，我不知道，弹簧高跷，那是什么？我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州州立大学的KCB的粉丝提问，
in State College, Pennsylvania, who wanted to know, what was that? Steve Burgess said it was embarrassingly simple. That's a quote. It was an aluminum cane that they put up through his hand, and he's sitting on the handle. Yeah. Ow. No. Ow. He had to have at least one sore butt cheek there. Well, I was so tickled by this next moment when Jim's like, I'm gonna have to do this and Dwight's like, I know.
他想知道，那是什么？史蒂夫·伯吉斯说这尴尬地简单。这是一句名言。那是一根铝制的拐杖，他们把它从他的手上穿上去，然后他坐在把手上。哎哟。不。哎哟。他的屁股上至少得有一个酸痛的肉块。好吧，接下来的这个时刻让我觉得太好笑了，当吉姆说，我得这么做，而德怀特说，我知道。
Did you hear the noise that Rain makes this Dwight when Jim topples him over? No. It made me laugh so hard. I emailed Cassie about it. She was like, yeah, that's ridiculous. It cracked us up. You have to hear it.
你听到雷恩扮演的德怀特在吉姆把他推倒时发出的声音了吗？没有。这把我逗得哈哈大笑。我为此给Cassie发了邮件。她的反应是，没错，太荒谬了。这把我们逗乐了。你必须听听。
That's real creative. You know what, you're right. It's not my best, because you could easily just bend over and pick that up, right? I could. I just don't feel like a lizard because you're sitting. Standing. OK.
这真有创意。你知道吗，你是对的。这不是我最好的表现，因为你可以轻易地弯腰把那个捡起来，对吧？我可以。我只是不想像个蜥蜴一样，因为你坐着。站着。好吧。
Don't. Because you're sitting. Standing. You know, I have to do this. I know. Huh! Because you're sitting? Standing. You know I have to do this. I know. Ah! Ha ha ha ha ha!
别。因为你坐着。站着。你知道，我得这么做。我知道。哈！因为你坐着？站着。你知道我得这么做。我知道。啊！哈哈哈哈哈！
Wah! Ah! Like, what is that cartoon, yell? Oh my gosh, it got me so tickled. So this episode starts with Jim in Andy's office. Andy is signing paperwork. He really loves signing his full name. They're just having some chit chat.
哇！啊！就像，那是什么卡通尖叫？天哪，把我逗乐了。所以这一集是以吉姆在安迪的办公室开始的。安迪在签署文件。他真的很喜欢签署他的全名。他们只是在闲聊。
Then all of a sudden, they're big, big, big on the window. And it's Robert and he is so flustered. Like, we've never seen him this flustered. He's panicking. He's like, hey, in four seconds. My wife is walking through that door. She wants a job here under no circumstances. Can you give her a job here?
然后突然间，他们用力、用力、用力地拍打窗户。那是罗伯特，他慌乱极了。就像，我们从未见过他这么慌乱。他在恐慌。他说，嘿，四秒钟内。我妻子就要走进那扇门了。她想在这里找份工作，在任何情况下都不行。你能在这里给她一份工作吗？
Understood? And then he runs away. It was so amazing. It was so good. Yeah. Miles McNutt had something to say about this scene. Miles, you did? Yes.
听懂了吗？然后他跑开了。太棒了。太棒了。是的。迈尔斯·麦克纳特（Miles McNutt）对这个场景有话要说。迈尔斯，你真的说过？是的。
Reviewer Miles McNutt wrote for the AV Club, quote, the very first scene of Mrs. California suggests the potential for a very smart episode of the office. Ooh. Does that mean so? You've been saying it ultimately failed to press. suggest the potential for a very smart episode of the office. Ooh. Does that mean so? It's been so ultimately failed to press. Why do I feel like there's a however coming?
评论家迈尔斯·麦克纳特为《影音俱乐部》（AV Club）撰文写道：“《加州太太》的开场白暗示了《办公室》制作一集非常聪明的剧集的潜力。”噢。是这样吗？你刚才一直在说它最终未能达到预期。暗示了《办公室》制作一集非常聪明的剧集的潜力。噢。是这样吗？它最终未能达到预期。为什么我觉得“然而”马上就要来了？
He ended up giving it a C plus. But I wanna say this was an amazing opening scene. Amazing. I agree. And right away Jim was like, I am out of this. That's right. Because Andy's like, what was that about? And Jim's like, I am out of this. That's right. Because Andy's like, what was that about? And Jim's like, I don't know, he wasn't talking to me.
他最后给它打了个C加。但我想说这是一个惊艳的开场场景。惊艳。我同意。吉姆马上就说，我不管这事了。没错。因为安迪说，刚才那是怎么回事？吉姆说，我不管这事了。没错。因为安迪说，刚才那是怎么回事？吉姆说，我不知道，他又不是跟我说话。
I know this episode is called Mrs. California. But Jenna, when I was doing my research, I realized there was something I have been wanting to share with you all, and I haven't yet. It all started with an email to Joya, who you know, worked for NBC Digital. She always gives us great little tidbits. And I said, Joya, did you guys build anything out for the saber pyramid? She said, Oh, saber had an amazing website, right? We've talked about that. I put stuff in stories. One of the things I felt to see was Robert California's bio. Oh, he has quite the bio. It's clear that he wrote
我知道这一集叫《加州太太》。但珍娜，当我做研究时，我意识到有一件事我一直想跟你们大家分享，但我还没分享。这一切都始于给乔伊的一封电子邮件，你知道的，她在NBC数字部门工作。她总是给我们提供很好的小内幕消息。我说，乔伊，你们为塞伯（Saber）金字塔搭建了什么东西吗？她说，哦，塞伯有一个令人惊叹的网站，对吧？我们讨论过那个。我把东西放进故事里了。我没能看到的东西之一就是罗伯特·加州的个人简介。哦，他的个人简介相当丰富。很显然那是他自己写的
it himself. Oh, and it's on the Saber website. I would love to read it to you guys. Chief Executive Officer Robert California, one African story of creation depicts a bee carrying a mantis across a river. The river is wide, and the exhausted bee eventually leaves the mantis on a floating flower. The bee plants a seed in the mantis' body before dying. And the seed grows into the first human. All of you are the equivalent of that exhausted, primitive worker bee towing a dying, outmoded business behind you. And it has weakened every fiber in your pitiful bodies.
。哦，它就在塞伯的网站上。我很乐意读给你们听。首席执行官罗伯特·加州，一个非洲的创造故事描绘了一只蜜蜂带着一只螳螂过河。河很宽，筋疲力尽的蜜蜂最终把螳螂留在一朵漂浮的花上。蜜蜂在死前在螳螂的身体里种下一颗种子。这颗种子长成了第一个人类。你们所有人就相当于那只筋疲力尽的、原始的工蜂，身后拖着一项垂死的、过时的业务。这已经削弱了你们可怜身体里的每一根纤维。
I am commensurate with the first human, a mark of welcome change, an evolution, a visitude so powerful and so blinding that you'll need to put on a pair of blue blockers just to get through the day. I possess the fire of a young Egyptian protester and the restraint and stoicism of a wise Chinese village elder, an impeccable combination ideal for rejuvenating a regional paper distributor.
我与第一个人类相媲美，这是一个受欢迎的改变、进化、变革的标志，它是如此强大和耀眼，以至于你需要戴上一副蓝光阻隔眼镜才能度过这一天。我拥有年轻的埃及抗议者的火焰和一位睿智的中国乡村老人的克制与斯多葛主义，这是一个重振区域纸张分销商的理想完美结合。
I know what you're thinking. Will you be able to keep up with the demand? Will you live up to my exceedingly high standards? Will you be replaced by someone faster and much, much more attractive? My advice is to never stop asking yourself those questions. This is his bio. This is his bio. I am now dying to write a bio where within my bio is the phrase, I know what you're thinking. I sure starred for nine seasons on the office. I know what you're thinking. I mean, this is the oddest bite. This wasn't like a letter.
我知道你在想什么。你能够跟上需求吗？你能不负我极高的标准吗？你会不会被一个更快、更美、更吸引人的人取代？我的建议是永远不要停止问自己这些问题。这就是他的个人简介。这就是他的个人简介。我现在渴望写一份个人简介，在我的个人简介里有这样一句话：我知道你在想什么。我确实在《办公室》里主演了九季。我知道你在想什么。我的意思是，这是最奇怪的个人简介。这不是一封信。
Do this under bio. This is next to his photo, chief executive officer, Robert California. Incredible. Starts with the story of a bee and a mantis, floating down a river. Isn't that exactly what you expect though? Incredible. Thank you. Anyway, I have been meaning to share that for weeks now.
把这当作个人简介。这在他的照片旁边，首席执行官罗伯特·加州。难以置信。以一只蜜蜂和一只螳螂顺流而下的故事开始。难道这不正是你所期待的吗？难以置信。谢谢。总之，我几周来一直想分享这个。
Well, Robert is going to introduce his wife, Mrs. California, to the bullpen. Susan, please call me Susan. Yeah, please call me Susan. Robert is going to share that last night at dinner, they were discussing her return to work, and she's here to see if there's a position for her. And he's going to jump on this. He's going to say, oh, you know, that's so wonderful, but we're, I mean, we're completely staffed up. Immediately, he's trying to shut it down, because Robert had banged on the window. This whole scene, Jenna, was so rich to me. Just the sentence where he says last night at dinner, we were discussing her, getting back into the workplace.
好吧，罗伯特要把他的妻子加州太太介绍给开放式办公室。苏珊，请叫我苏珊。是的，请叫我苏珊。罗伯特将分享昨晚在晚餐时，他们讨论了她重返工作岗位的事，她来这里看看是否有适合她的职位。他要抓住这个机会。他会说，哦，你知道，那太棒了，但我们，我的意思是，我们的员工已经满员了。他立刻试图阻止它，因为罗伯特拍打了窗户。整个场景，珍娜，对我来说太丰富了。仅仅是他说的“昨晚在晚餐时，我们讨论了她重返工作岗位”的那句话，
I was like, oh, that was so layered. I bet that was the most painful, awkward, layered conversation. Those are the kind of scenes I love like in a one act play. I want to see the scene between Robert and Susan at dinner where she basically says, I want to go the scene between Robert and Susan at dinner, where she basically says, I want to go back to work. You know, Maritiri doesn't have any lines in this. And yet, like you're saying,
我就觉得，哦，这太有层次了。我敢打赌那是痛苦、尴尬、充满层次感的一次谈话。我喜欢那种像独幕剧一样的场景。我想看罗伯特和苏珊在晚宴上的场景，她基本上说的是，我想去——看罗伯特和苏珊在晚宴上的场景，她基本上说的是，我想回去工作。你知道，莫拉·蒂尔尼在这集里没有任何台词。然而，正如你所说，
there is so much playing out on her face. Yes, the way she looks at him. Yes, when Andy says we're completely staffed up, oh my gosh, she turns her head and looks at Robert. And they're whole dinner. They're whole dinner conversation. Yeah. All of it. That history is there. Yeah. Because you know, he made fake promises to her that he never intended on keeping. And right away, she's like, and then he looks at Andy and kind of does a weird twitch with the sign goes, I think we can see
她的脸上演出了那么多戏份。是的，她看着他的眼神。是的，当安迪说我们完全满员时，天哪，她转过头看着罗伯特。还有他们整场晚餐。他们整场的晚餐谈话。是的。那段历史都在那里。是的。因为你知道，他对她做出过从未打算兑现的虚假承诺。她立刻就觉得，然后他看着安迪，对着手势做了个奇怪的抽搐，说道，我想我们可以先看看
the options first. Yes. Like basically like Andy, you idiot. Let it play out a little bit. So it's more believable. We had a fan mail flurry about this scene. People pointed out that Robert California and his wife are wearing color coordinated outfits. The turquoise. Yes, and the black.
这些选择。是的。基本上就像安迪，你这个笨蛋。让它稍微发展一下。这样才更可信。我们收到了关于这个场景的大量粉丝邮件。人们指出罗伯特·加州和他的妻子穿着色彩协调的服装。绿松石色。是的，还有黑色。
And they wanted to know if it was intentional or just a weird coincidence. Charlie Grande, remember I said he directed this episode and I traded messages with him. He said it was a conscious decision to make it look like Robert and Susan are quite literally on the same team. And then if you notice the way Andy's dressed,
他们想知道这是刻意为之还是只是一个奇怪的巧合。查理·格兰迪，还记得我说过他导演了这一集，我和他交换了信息。他说这是一个有意识的决定，让罗伯特和苏珊看起来字面意思上是在同一个团队里。然后如果你注意安迪的穿着方式，
it's really, it's like a completely different color palette and it's made to further isolate him. And Charlie said, good catch everyone. This is the stuff I love. These are the little details I love to learn. Well, next up Dwight is going to knock on Darryl's door. He's going to tell Darryl that he has started Dwight's roots gym for muscles. You know, Darryl was saying he wanted to start working out. Well, Dwight's going to solve that problem for him. Dwight is always looking for the side hustle. He's got capping corner. He owns the business park now. He tried to have a daycare. Now he's going to have gym for muscles.
真的，这就像一个完全不同的调色板，这样做是为了进一步孤立他。查理说，大家都抓得很准。这就是我喜欢的东西。这些是我喜欢了解的小细节。好吧，接下来德怀特要去敲达里尔的门。他要告诉达里尔他开了“德怀特肌肉根源健身房”。你知道达里尔说过他想开始健身。好吧，德怀特要为他解决那个问题。德怀特总是在寻找副业。他有咖啡角。他现在拥有那个商业园区。他试图开一家日托中心。现在他要开肌肉健身房了。
In Dwight's talking head, he says that obese people in the building are putting a strain on resources. For example, the chairs wear out faster. We had a fan question from Christian H. and Independence Missouri who said, there are two previous office episodes all about Michael having to buy chairs. And Chair model, he's buying a chair for himself and in the surplus, they're debating between buying chairs or a new copier. So my question is, which is it? Does the office buy the chairs or the building? Are you asking me? I think Christian has a little task. Christian, Jenna just looked at me like, and what do you think, Angela? I think, um, why is Dwight worried about the chair so much?
在德怀特的采访独白中，他说大楼里的肥胖人群给资源造成了负担。例如，椅子磨损得更快。我们收到了来自密苏里州独立市的克里斯蒂安·H的粉丝提问，他说，前面有两集《办公室》完全是关于迈克尔不得不买椅子的。在《椅子模特》中，他在为自己买椅子，而在《盈余》中，他们一直在争论是买椅子还是买新复印机。所以我的问题是，到底是哪个？是办公室买椅子还是大楼买椅子？你是在问我吗？我觉得克里斯蒂安出了个小难题。克里斯蒂安，珍娜刚才看着我的眼神就像在说，安吉拉，你觉得呢？我觉得，嗯，为什么德怀特这么担心椅子？
I think the building buys the chairs. That makes no sense. Well, they don't ask me. Why did we have a whole episode where we argued over what to do with our surplus if the building would have just bought us chairs anyway? I don't know. I mean, I think very clearly the office has a budget to buy chairs for the office, but you know, there are other chairs. There are the chairs of caffeine corner, perhaps.
我觉得是大楼买椅子。这毫无道理。好吧，没人问我。如果我们整个大楼本来就会帮我们买椅子的的话，为什么我们还要专门拍一集来争论怎么处理我们的盈余呢？我不知道。我的意思是，我很清楚办公室有预算为办公室买椅子，但你知道，还有其他椅子。也许有咖啡角的椅子。
There are building chairs. The lobby sofa. Yes. There you go. Hmm. Maybe it's both. Case of the chairs. Well, Andy is going to start showing Susan around.
有大楼的椅子。大堂沙发。就是这样。嗯。也许两者都有。椅子案。好吧，安迪要开始带苏珊参观了。
And right before they start their tour, she says goodbye to a few folks. Yes. And she gets Ryan's name wrong. As she's saying goodbye, she calls him Brian. And he is not pleased. This is something I struggle with. Anyone else out there like Ryan and Brian, Craig and Greg, Kristen, Christine, Tim and Tom.
就在他们开始参观之前，她向几个人告别。是的。她把瑞安的名字叫错了。在她告别时，她叫他布赖恩。他不高兴了。这也是我挣扎的一点。外面的其他人也有同感吗，比如瑞安和布赖恩、克雷格和格雷格、克里斯滕、克里斯蒂娜、蒂姆和汤姆。
I'm gonna get it wrong guys. Tamara, Tamara, I'm gonna get it wrong. And I'm so sorry, I don't mean anything by it. It's a hard thing sometimes to dial in, wait, which one was it Ryan or Ryan? And then, you know, I wonder if, like, behind your back, someone's like, bitch. There are so many parents at my kid's school,
我肯定会叫错的，伙计们。塔玛拉，塔玛拉，我肯定会叫错的。我很抱歉，我不是故意的。有时候要拨对这个真的很难，等等，到底是瑞安还是布赖恩？然后，你知道，我在想，就像，在你背后，会不会有人说，碧池。我孩子的学校里有那么多家长，
who were probably introduced to me in the beginning. But now we're like five grades deep. It's too late, it's too late. You've got the name wrong late, it's too late. You've got the name wrong and it's too late. There's a dad at our school who calls everyone friend. Oh, I don't think he knows the names name. No, but I can't do it, I can't pull that off. Yeah, my husband does a lot of like,
他们可能在一开始向我做过自我介绍。但现在我们已经跨过了五个年级。太晚了，太晚了。名字叫错了，而且太晚了。名字叫错了，而且太晚了。我们学校有个爸爸管所有人都叫“朋友”。哦，我觉得他不知道他们的名字。不，但我做不到，我做不到那种操作。是的，我丈夫经常说，
what's up buddy? And I'm like, you don't, just don't. Men can do it better. Stop saying buddy, we all know you don't know their name. Men have dude, buddy, man. I know. We got nothing. We got lady. That's it.
怎么了，老兄？我说，你别，别这样。男人能做得更好。别再叫老兄了，我们都知道你不知道他们的名字。男人有 dude（老兄）、buddy（兄弟）、man（伙计）。我知道。我们什么都没有。我们有 lady（女士）。就这样。
But you have to, like, if I am familiar enough with someone to call them lady, I know their name. Right. Not gonna call, you know, someone I rarely interact with. Play hey lady. Yeah, good morning lady. No, I don't think so. Mm-hmm.
但你必须，如果你和我足够熟，可以叫我 lady，我肯定知道你的名字。对。不会叫一个，你知道的，我很少互动的人。说“嘿，女士”。是的，早安，女士。不，我不这么认为。嗯哼。
But isn't this everyone? We all suffer from this, right? Guys, I mean, everybody has this problem. How many people out there hear a name once and they lock into it? The percentage must be small. Can we just all agree that we're not gonna be offended if someone has to ask us our names 70 times?
但难道不是所有人这样吗？我们都深受其害，对吧？伙计们，我的意思是，每个人都有这个问题。外面有多少人听到一个名字一次就能牢牢记住？这个百分比一定很小。我们能不能达成共识：如果有人不得不问我们70次名字，我们不会被冒犯？
Can that just be like a collective... Forgiveness. We just forgive this. We release that. There's so much to be stressed about until we can be judgy about other stuff. I wanna just drop the name forgetting thing. Let's just drop it. It's fine.
这难道不能算是一种集体……原谅吗？我们就原谅这个吧。我们放下这个。有那么多事情要烦恼，直到我们可以对其他事情评头品足。我只想抛弃这种忘记名字的事情。我们把它放下吧。没关系的。
I don't care if you forgot my name. It's fine. I don't know how we get this out there. I feel like it needs to be on a valid or something. We wanna collect collective forgiveness. Collective forgiveness on names. Some days I'm amazing at it. Some days I crush it, but then there's my Ryan, Brian days.
我不在乎你忘了我的名字。没关系的。我不知道我们怎么能把这个宣传出去。我觉得它需要出现在某种选票上什么的。我们想要集体原谅。对名字的集体原谅。有些日子我在这方面强得可怕。有些日子我能搞定，但随后就迎来了我的瑞安-布赖恩日。
Well, Andy's going to begin his tour of Dunderclund at reception. Aaronville. Yes. Should we have two secretaries, two receptionists? Andy doesn't think so. Maybe Susan would be good for sales. Let's go talk to Jim, where Andy sure Jim's gonna have my back. He's gonna make sales sound horrible.
好了，安迪将从前台开始他的邓德米夫巡视。亚伦维尔。是的。我们应该有两个秘书、两个前台吗？安迪不这么认为。也许苏珊去销售部不错。我们去找吉姆谈谈，安迪确信吉姆会支持他。他会把销售工作说得极其糟糕。
But then Dwight comes over and makes sales sound amazing. So much so that after her first sale, Susan and Dwight are gonna go have a glass of red wine and trade their lists of best animals. Their rankings. She's fitting in pretty well with Dwight. This really stresses out Andy. He's like, oh, how am I going to do this? And lady, I think we're about to learn something that might confirm what Michael knew all along. Proof of Phyllis' flatulence.
但接着德怀特走过来，把销售工作说得太棒了。以至于在她完成第一笔交易后，苏珊和德怀特要去喝一杯红酒，并交换他们最喜欢的动物名单。他们的排名。她和德怀特相处得挺融洽的。这让安迪感到压力山大。他心想，哦，我该怎么做呢？天哪，我想我们马上要了解到一件事，它可能会证实迈克尔一直以来的看法。菲利斯放屁的证据。
Yes, Andy has a talking head about why couldn't Phyllis have one of her room clearing farts? This definitely made me wonder if she really tutored at her wedding after all. That's what I think, right? Yes, here's one other thing I want to say about this Andy talking head. There were several candy bag ults for it
是的，安迪有一个单人访谈，谈到为什么菲利斯就不能放一个能把全屋人熏走的屁呢？这绝对让我怀疑她婚礼上到底是不是真的当过家教。我是这么想的，对吧？是的，关于安迪的这段单人访谈，我还想说另一件事。为此有几个备选的糖果袋笑话。
That were so hilarious. There were two pages of candy bag ults Three of them really made me laugh hard and I want to share them, okay? Andy, how am I supposed to pull this off? Kevin Ward deodorant today? Angela smiled Meredith eight before she drank G G, thanks team, way to go. Here's the other one. How am I supposed to pull this off? Creed talked to her without a single spit bubble forming in the corner of his mouth. Really? That hasn't happened in a decade. Last one. This is one where you know sometimes they throw a crazy one in there. Yeah. How am I supposed to pull this off?
简直太搞笑了。有两页纸的糖果袋笑话。其中三个真的让我大笑不已，我想和大家分享一下，好吗？安迪，我该怎么搞定这事？凯文今天用了沃德除臭剂？安吉拉笑了，梅雷迪思喝G前先喝了G，谢谢团队，干得漂亮。这是另一个。我该怎么搞定这事？克里德和她说话时，嘴角没有冒出一个口水泡。真的吗？这十年里都没发生过这种事。最后一个。有时候他们会抛出一个疯狂的梗。是的。我该怎么搞定这事？
I'm doing my best to make these assholes look like assholes, but these assholes keep acting like pretty good people to work with. These are all amazing. Oh my gosh. I know it was really good candy bag. Lady, thank you so much for sharing those. I think it's also really great for people out there who are maybe wanting to be writers or artists or whatever to see how like our writers,
我尽力让这群混蛋看起来像混蛋，但这群混蛋却一直在表现得像很好的工作伙伴。这些都太棒了。噢天哪。我知道那个糖果袋笑话真的很棒。天哪，非常感谢你分享这些。我也觉得，对于那些可能想成为作家、艺术家或者其他什么的人来说，看到我们的编剧，
they didn't write one talking head or one button for a scene. They wrote a bunch. Oh yeah. You know, it's like you try everything and you see what ends up working best. But there's so many good ones, like any one of those would have cracked me up. Same. Well now Dwight is going to unveil his amazingly fancy gym to Daryl and by amazingly fancy, it looks like something out of a scene in SAW 5. Yes, this gym. It reminded me of the strongest man competition. Do you watch the strongest man competition?
他们没有只为一个场景写一个单人访谈或一个包袱。他们写了一堆。噢是的。你知道的，就像你尝试各种方法，然后看哪种效果最好。但有太多精彩的桥段了，随便哪一个都能逗得我哈哈大笑。我也是。现在德怀特要向达里尔展示他那极其奢华的健身房，说它极其奢华，它看起来就像《电锯惊魂5》里的场景。是的，这个健身房。让我想到了最强壮男人比赛。你看过最强壮男人比赛吗？
Well, is that the one where they have to throw a log in the air? Yes. So Dwight's gym, it has like, there's just like a stump with like an ass and there's just like gravel buckets and phone book ripping. So the strongest man competition, it started in 1977. I looked up a description of it, and this could be written by Dwight. It's amazing. Let's hear it. The world's strongest man competition
嗯，那是让他们把圆木扔到空中的那个比赛吗？是的。所以德怀特的健身房，就像是有个带屁股的树桩，还有碎石桶和撕电话本。所以最强壮男人比赛，始于1977年。我查了它的描述，这简直就像是德怀特写的。太惊人了。我们听听看。世界最强壮男人比赛
is about more than just force. It is about stamina, skill, tactics, training, and strategy. Every event is designed to push the strong men to their absolute limits, challenging not only their physical strength, but their agility and mental toughness too. Doesn't that seem like? That sounds very Dwight.
不仅仅关乎力量。它关乎耐力、技巧、战术、训练和策略。每一个项目旨在将大力士们推向他们的绝对极限，不仅挑战他们的体力，还挑战他们的敏捷性和心理韧性。这听起来是不是很像？听起来非常德怀特。
Very Dwight. But yeah, they like lift giant tree trunks and boulders, and then they have an event. This is the one that gets me. The vehicle pull. Oh, did they put the thing around their waist and then after walk, pulling a car or something? Yes, but they don't just pull cars.
非常德怀特。但是是的，他们要举起巨大的树干和巨石，然后他们还有一个项目。这个项目最让我惊叹。拉汽车。哦，他们是把带子系在腰上，然后往前走，拉一辆汽车什么的吗？是的，但他们不只拉汽车。
They pull all kinds of stuff. And one time they pulled planes, a plane. Is it stripped down or is it an actual full plane? I am not exactly sure. I mean, listen, stripped down or not is still a fucking plane. It's very giant. And they have to wait and everything.
他们拉各种各样的东西。有一次他们拉了飞机，一架飞机。是拆卸过的还是真正的完整飞机？我不太确定。听着，不管拆没拆，那都他妈是一架飞机。非常巨大。而且他们还得等风向什么的。
And then the way they do it is it's like, they have to drag it a hundred feet in the quickest time possible. So whoever drags at the fastest is the winner of that competition. But like each year it's a different vehicle. And it kind of matches either like a strong man's profession like one time there was a guy who was a firefighter.
然后他们拉的方式是，必须在最短的时间内把它拖动一百英尺。所以谁拖得最快谁就是那场比赛的赢家。但每年拉的交通工具都不同。它有点匹配大力士的职业，比如有一次有个家伙是个消防员。
So they all, Fire truck. They pulled fire trucks. And then another year they pulled a mining coal car in honor of the coal miners in West Virginia. And also, it's not always on land. Sometimes they pull stuff across like ice or snow or sand. Oh my God.
所以他们都，消防车。他们拉消防车。然后另一次他们为了向西弗吉尼亚州的煤矿工人致敬，拉了一辆运煤矿车。而且，它并不总是在陆地上。有时他们会在冰、雪或沙地上拉东西。噢天哪。
Can you imagine pulling a vehicle through sand? No, I can barely walk like on the beach and then I'm sore. But anyway, I did want to shout out this year's winner. Strongest man competition goes to Mitchell Hooper. He's the first Canadian to win. Way to go Mitchell. But they would love Dwight's gym. They would be all over. They'd be like, this is amazing. This is literally how they train. Darryl's not loving it. No, he wants a real gym. This whole gym storyline was so much bigger, almost all the deleted scenes are gym storylines. Oh, wow.
你能想象在沙地上拉一辆车吗o不，我在海滩上走路都勉强，然后就会肌肉酸痛。不管怎样，我要向今年的冠军致敬。最强壮男人比赛的冠军是米奇·胡珀。他是第一个获胜的加拿大人。干得好，米奇。但他们一定会喜欢德怀特的健身房。他们会完全迷上。他们会觉得，这太棒了。这就是他们的训练方式。达里尔可不喜欢。不，他想要个真正的健身房。这个健身房的故事线原本要大得多，几乎所有删减片段都是健身房的故事线。哦，哇。
Not Jim helper. Not Jim helper. Jim muscles. Jim muscles. But I'll share more of those later. Next up we have one of my favorite scenes in the episode, which is when Andy meets with Mr. and Mrs. California in his office. And no matter what job Susan says she would like to do,
不是吉姆·哈珀。不是吉姆·哈珀。吉姆肌肉。吉姆肌肉。但我稍后会分享更多这些内容。接下来我们来看本集中我最喜欢的场景之一，那就是安迪在办公室里会见加利福尼亚夫妇。不管苏珊说她想做什么工作，
Andy has a reason why she can't. And Robert has a reason why she can. Here's what I didn't understand. In this moment, Robert would have been off the hook. Susan actually says, this is very uncomfortable. Obviously, there's no place for me here. So thank you for trying. Why don't we just let it go?
安迪总有理由说她不行。而罗伯特总有理由说她行。这是我不理解的地方。在这个时刻，罗伯特本可以脱身的。苏珊其实说，这太尴尬了。很显然，这里没有我的位子。所以谢谢你们的尝试。我们为什么不就此作罢呢？
And Robert can't let it go. He needs so desperately, I feel like, to look like the good guy to her. Mm-hmm. That he's like, I'm the CEO Andy. Surely you want to owe me one. Yes. Poor Andy. And Ed's performance was so amazing. Like you could feel how confused he was. We had a fan question from Mojo and Michigan. How uncomfortable was Ed filming these scenes where Robert keeps saying there's got to be somewhere for her to fit in? I was so uncomfortable this whole episode,
而罗伯特却放不下。我感觉他太急切地想在她面前树立好人形象了。嗯哼。以至于他说，我是CEO，安迪。你肯定想欠我一个人情吧。是的。可怜的安迪。埃德的表演太棒了。就像你能感受到他是多么困惑。我们有一个来自密歇根州莫吉的粉丝提问：埃德在拍摄这些罗伯特不停地说必须有个地方适合她的场景时，有多尴尬？我整集都觉得好尴尬，
not as bad as Scott's tauts, but still really uncomfortable. Yeah, it's pretty cringy. Well, Charlie Grandy said it was extremely uncomfortable, this scene. He said the biggest challenge of this episode for him was trying to escalate the discomfort while still keeping it enjoyable to watch, which is that's the
虽然没到斯科特的学费那种程度，但确实真的很尴尬。是的，挺让人脚趾抠地的。嗯，查理·格兰迪说这场戏极其尴尬。他说对他来说这一集最大的挑战是试图升级这种不适感，同时又要保持观赏性，这就是所谓的
sweet spot, you know. He said that since this was his first time directing a complete episode, Paul Lieberstein was really helpful in suggesting shots and camera movements. And in this scene, for example, you might notice, they start wide, they even start with like a spy shot through the window, and as the scene goes on, they go closer and closer and closer, it ends on like a super close-up of Andy nervously smiling, and Charlie said that was intentional as a way of building that discomfort. Yeah, and ultimately Andy's like, fine, okay, welcome aboard. Yeah.
最佳平衡点，你知道的。他说由于这是他第一次导演完整的一集，保罗·利伯斯坦在建议镜头和运镜方面真的帮了很大忙。比如在这场戏中，你可能会注意到，他们从广角开始，甚至从透过窗户的偷窥视角开始，随着场景的进展，他们越来越近、越来越近、越来越近，最后定格在安迪紧张微笑的特写上，查理说这是故意安排的，作为建立这种不适感的一种方式。是的，最后安迪只好说，好吧，好吧，欢迎加入。是的。
And then she's like, yay! And Robert just shoots him a dagger. Yeah. It's amazing. So good. Because Andy knows immediately he's messed up. Well, let's take a break and we get back. We'll see what Andy's going to do to solve this problem. We're back and now it's just Andy and Susan in Andy's office.
然后她高兴地说，太棒了！而罗伯特狠狠地瞪了他一眼。是的。太棒了。太精彩了。因为安迪立刻就知道自己搞砸了。好吧，我们休息一下，回来后。我们将看看安迪将如何解决这个麻烦。我们回来了，现在办公室里只有安迪和苏珊。
And Andy's going to get a phone call. It's Robert. And when Andy answers, he says, say hello, grandma. And Andy says, hi, Gam Gam. And then Robert says, hold one finger up to Susan, you'll just be a second. You numbschool. You're given a very simple task. I could not have been more clear with you. Now say, are you taking your medicine? And Andy says, are you taking your med meds? And Robert says, why can you not say exactly what I tell you? I thought that was so funny. So funny.
然后安迪要接个电话。是罗伯特。安迪接起电话时，罗伯特说，打个招呼吧，奶奶。安迪说，嗨，奶奶。然后罗伯特说，对苏珊竖起一根手指，你只要一秒钟。你这个笨蛋。交给你这么简单的一个任务。我跟你说得不能再清楚了。现在说，你在按时吃药吗？安迪说，你在吃药吗？罗伯特说，为什么我告诉你什么你就不能原样说出来？我觉得这太搞笑了。太搞笑了。
There's two frustrations happening in this conversation. But ultimately what Robert is going to say to him is, undo this or else. Yeah. I like that phrase. I want to start using that. Like if Lee makes plans and I don't want to do them, I'm going to say undo this.
这场对话中包含着两种挫败感。但罗伯特最终要对他说的是，撤回这个决定，否则后果自负。Yeah。我喜欢这个短语。我想开始用它。比如如果李做了计划而我不想去，我就要说撤回这个。
Undo this. I need you say undo this. Undo this. I need you to undo this. Yeah, it's like that. The line that really stuck with me in succession when he goes, you are not serious people. Yes. What if we just start speaking in our favorite quotes? Oh my gosh.
撤回这个。我需要你说撤回这个。撤回这个。我需要你撤回这个。是的，就像那样。继承之战中真正印在我脑海里的台词是他说，你们都不是严肃的人。是的。如果我们开始用我们最喜欢的名言对话会怎么样？噢天哪。
Next up Dwight is going to announce to the bullpen that his gym is up and running. He has gotten some real equipment. We saw it delivered. Really nice equipment. This is a nice gym now. It appears so, but nobody really wants to sign up. Everybody has an excuse.
接下来，德怀特将向员工大厅宣布他的健身房已经开业并投入使用了。他买了一些真正的器材。我们看到它送货上门了。非常棒的器材。现在这是个不错的健身房了。看起来是这样，但实际上没有人想报名。每个人都有借口。
Including Kelly who says her sneakers are like a gym for your feet. Mm-hmm. Lady. Oh my gosh, do you remember these sneakers? They were the sketchers, sneakers. Oh, with the foamy, memory foam? We got a fan letter from Mary Grace in Athens, Georgia, who said, the shoes Kelly's wearing are sketcher shapeups,
包括凯莉，她说她的运动鞋就像是你双脚的健身房。嗯哼。天哪。噢天哪，你还记得这些运动鞋吗？那是斯凯奇的运动鞋。哦，带有那种泡沫材质、记忆棉的？我们收到了来自佐治亚州雅典市玛丽·格雷斯的粉丝来信，她说，凯莉脚上穿的是斯凯奇塑身鞋，
and I just learned about these in class! She's an advertising grad student, okay? Mary says, allow me to deep dive for you. Sketchers' shapeups were a shoe with Kim Kardashian as the spokesperson, immediately at tracks that Kelly would be wearing these shoes. 100%. In the ads, Kim says she was able to ditch her personal trainer because of the shoes. Because the idea was that these shoes were all the workout you needed,
我刚好在课上学到这个！她是一名广告专业的研究生，好吗？玛丽说，请允许我为你深度剖析一下。斯凯奇塑身鞋是一款由金·卡戴珊代言的鞋子，凯莉会穿这双鞋绝对不让人意外。百分之百。在广告中，金说因为有了这双鞋，她可以甩掉私人教练。因为当时的理念是，这双鞋就是你所需要的所有锻炼，
because they had that little foam thing that you were talking about in the shoe. There were lawsuits filed against sketchers for these misleading ads because they conducted studies on the target market and they found that most people were misled into thinking that the shoes alone would make them healthier and most of the people who bought the shoes gained weight because they ditched the gym.
因为鞋子里有你刚才提到的那个小泡沫垫。由于这些误导性广告，斯凯奇遭到了起诉，因为他们对目标市场进行了研究，发现大多数人都被误导，以为仅靠这些鞋子就能让自己更健康，而大部分买鞋的人反而因为放弃了健身房而体重增加。
I looked into this, sketchers had to pay $40 million to settle this lawsuit of these shoes. Oh my god. That Kelly is wearing. Yes. The FTC settlement. Wow. That's an expensive pair of shoes. Thank you, Mary Grace, for that amazing bit of info. I have a little accounting shout-out because I loved, loved, loved whenever the writers would write something for Angela Oscar and Kevin that was just full of assumed history. Even if it was just a throwaway line, because you know, Oscar says like I need more gym drama and he starts listing all the different dynamics that the gym where he works out and Angela goes, enough Oscar, enough. And you just know that he comes into work and he's like, you would not believe who's doing leg day to day and taking up all the machines. Like you just imagine his gripe over there and Angela is just over it. I feel like this
我查了一下，斯凯奇不得不支付4000万美元来和解这双鞋的诉讼。噢天哪。凯莉脚上穿的那双。是的。联邦贸易委员会的和解协议。哇。那可是一双昂贵的鞋子。谢谢玛丽·格雷斯提供的那条精彩信息。我要做个小小的会计部门致谢，因为我太爱太爱太爱每当编剧为安吉拉、奥斯卡和凯文写一些充满假定历史的台词时。哪怕只是句随意的台词，因为你知道的，奥斯卡说我需要更多健身房八卦，他开始列举他在健身房锻炼时的各种人事动态，安吉拉说，够了，奥斯卡，够了。你就是知道他来上班时会说，你绝对不敢相信今天是谁在练腿日占用了所有器械。就像你能想象他在那里的抱怨，而安吉拉已经听腻了。我觉得这
is a little bit of a call back too. Remember in the previous episode when Oscar knew who was the most fit person when they were looking for warehouse people? He talks a lot about his gym. Susan has arrived in HR. She's going to do her, I guess, her paperwork, right? Her start-up paperwork. And Toby asked her for her passport. She just, in one one sentence destroys him.
其实也是一个小彩蛋。还记得上一集里，当他们在寻找仓库人员时，奥斯卡一眼就看出谁的体能最好吗？他经常聊起他的健身房。苏珊已经到了人力资源部。她要做她，我想是她的入职手续，对吧？她的入职文书工作。托比向她索要护照。她仅仅用了一句话就把他击溃了。
I know. She's like, well, no, I mean, who walks around with her passport. And Toby's like, well, I do, you know, just in case there's an adventure. She goes, have you been on any adventures? He's like, no. Here was my question. Does he keep his passport on him at all times for adventures? Or in case he has to flee because he is the scrant and
我知道。她说，呃，没有，我是说，谁会随身带着护照呢。托比说，嗯，我带啊，你知道的，以防万一有什么冒险活动。她问，你有过什么冒险经历吗？他说，没有。我的问题是。他为了冒险随时随地都带着护照吗？还是以防他必须逃跑，因为他就是斯克兰顿
sprinkler? Well, there you go. Evidence of strangling? Maybe so. We had a fan catch in this scene that so delighted me. I didn't notice it when I watched the episode, but when I went back to check after I read this fan question, I laughed out loud. What?
绞杀魔？好吧，给你找到了。勒死人的证据？也许是的。我们在这一幕中发现了一个粉丝捕捉到的细节，让我太开心了。我看这一集时没注意到，但在读了这位粉丝的问题后，我回去核对时，忍不住笑出了声。什么？
Allison H. from Norway said, why is Toby's chair so low and his desk so high? Oh my gosh, Angela, his desk, it's in his armpit. I took pictures. Let me see, I'm putting on my glasses. Swipe to look. That is a far away and then I did a close up. What?
来自挪威的艾莉森·H说，为什么托比的椅子那么低，桌子那么高？噢天哪，安吉拉，他的桌子，都快夹到他咯吱窝了。我拍了照片。让我看看，我戴上眼镜。滑动查看。那是个远景，然后我拍了个特写。什么？
Who sits like that? You know what? I bet he got the crap chair that we kept passing around. Remember sometimes she would come on set, and you'd be like, who the heck put the crap chair? The one that would go up and down, and we kept moving it back to the annex or moving it somewhere else.
谁会那样坐呢？你知道吗？我打赌他坐的是我们一直在转手的那个破椅子。还记得有时你来片场，你会说，到底是谁把这把破椅子放这儿的？就是那种会上下滑动，然后我们一直把它搬回附楼或者其他地方的椅子。
But why was this allowed? Like you'd think like when it was time to shoot, they would be like, we got to get this guy. Yeah. Yeah. A real chair. So funny. It was delightful. Great catch, Allison.
但为什么这被允许呢？你本以为到拍摄的时候，他们会说，我们得给这家伙弄把。对。对。真正的椅子。太搞笑了。这太令人愉快了。艾莉森，捕捉得太棒了。
Andy has a new strategy for getting rid of Susan, which is that he's going to tell everyone in the bullpen to make it a miserable place to work, so miserable that she wants to leave by lunch. Yeah. And you know, Jim is gonna say, I don't think we should try to make this place seem unpleasant. I think we should just let this place crush her spirit by itself. I mean, it knows what it's doing. That made me laugh. I also love when Aaron goes, I know exactly what's stapler to give. Yes. And then we have to do anyone. It's like so ridiculous. That joke pays off so well. The wait, Ellie, like as Aaron placed it on the table, too.
安迪有了一个摆脱苏珊的新策略，那就是他要告诉员工大厅里的所有人，要把这里变成一个极其糟糕的工作场所，糟糕到让她午饭前就想离开。 yeah。你知道的，吉姆会说，我觉得我们不应该试图让这个地方显得不愉快。我觉得我们应该让这个地方自己去消磨她的斗志。我的意思是，它知道自己在做什么。这让我笑出声来。我也很喜欢艾伦说，我知道该给她哪个订书机。是的。然后我们得做任何人。这太荒谬了。这个笑话铺垫得太棒了。等等，艾莉，就像艾伦把它放在桌上时的动作一样。
Yeah. Look what I've had to deal with. Well, there was an alt talking head for Jim, and we find out a little something about Stanley that I want you all to hear. Okay. This whole thing is making me very uncomfortable. I'm not getting in between the boss and his wife,
是的。看看我得应付些什么。好吧，吉姆有一个备选的单人访谈，我们从中发现了一些关于斯坦利的小秘密，我想让你们大家都听听。好吧。这一切让我感到很不舒服。我才不要夹在老板和他的妻子中间，
so just ask me about something else. You know, Stanley's tie is really the story of the day. It's my birthday. Oh, this whole day has been Stanley's birthday? Yes, where is his cake? Where is his party? What has happened to the party plan and committee? And the best thing is when he says,
所以跟我聊点别的吧。你知道的，斯坦利的领带真的是当天的头条新闻。今天是我的生日。哦，这一整天都是斯坦利的生日？是的，他的蛋糕呢？他的派对呢？派对策划委员会怎么了？最棒的是当他说，
it is my birthday, they do a full pan shot of his tie. And his tie is a long blue fish. And the face of it is the end of the tie. Okay, it is a hilarious tie. He's clearly worn special for his birthday. In the whole episode, I rewatched it looking for this tie. You only see the top of it. Oh, wow!
今天是我的生日，镜头给了他的领带一个全景横摇特写。他的领带是一条长长的蓝色鱼。领带头就是鱼脸。好吧，这真是一条搞笑的领带。他显然是为生日特意戴的。整集中我重看就是为了找这条领带。你只能看到它的顶部。哦，哇！
You just see the blue top. But if it had ever shown him standing, you would have seen the fish face. But it's Stanley's birthday. Well, Pam is gone. Maybe she was in charge of this, but you know what? What is Kathy for? I don't know. Pam is gone. Angela's retired.
你只能看到蓝色的顶部。但如果镜头拍到他站着的话，你就会看到鱼脸了。但今天是斯坦利的生日。好吧，帕姆不在。也许她负责这个，但你知道吗？卡西是干什么用的？我不知道。帕姆不在。安吉拉退休了。
And Kathy is not doing her job. No, not if Pam was in charge of birthday, she's not. This is actually a good segue for me into the next scene. We're in the break room, and Oscars passing around is phone to kind of show everyone his like new puppy who has crawled into a Williams Sonoma ladle Gerald. Yes. And they're not letting Susan see the picture. They're kind of freezing her out of the conversation.
而卡西没有做好她的工作。不，如果帕姆负责生日的话，她可没闲着。这实际上对我来说是一个很好的过渡，进入下一个场景。我们在休息室里，奥斯卡正在传阅他的手机，向大家展示他那只爬进威廉·索诺玛汤勺杰拉德里的新小狗。是的。而且他们不让苏珊看照片。他们有点把她排除在对话之外了。
We got a fan question from a lot of people. Gina S in Iowa, Meredith and Sacramento, Lauren from Peoria, Illinois, who all said, Jenna had to leave the show temporarily for maternity leave, but it has always bothered me that Pam disappears with no fanfare. It seems like Jim would have been more excited to share the birth of their second child, or the story of the delivery, or maybe how mom and baby are doing something. There's nothing. Was there a writing decision to not focus on this part of their lives?
我们收到了很多人的粉丝提问。爱荷华州的吉娜·S、萨克拉门托的梅雷迪思、伊利诺伊州皮奥里亚的劳伦，他们都说，珍娜不得不暂时离开节目去休产假，但一直让我困扰的是，帕姆毫无铺垫地消失了。吉姆似乎应该对分享他们的第二个孩子的出生，或者分娩的故事，或者妈妈和宝宝的情况表现得更兴奋一些。什么都没有。剧组是有意不把镜头聚焦在他们生活的这一部分吗？
I really would have loved to see more of Jim acknowledging the addition to his family in this episode. Well, first of all, Steve Burgess reminded me that my son was born the Saturday before we started filming this episode. Aw, yeah. And as I was watching this episode, I too was surprised. That Pam had given birth and we do not mention it at all,
我真的很想看到吉姆在这集中更多地承认他的家庭又添新成员。嗯，首先，史蒂夫·伯吉斯提醒我，我儿子出生在我们开始拍摄这一集的那个星期六。噢，是的。当我观看这一集时，我也很惊讶。帕姆居然已经生了孩子，而我们压根没有提过，
so I asked Charlie Grantee about it. He was the director of this episode, but he's a long time writer. And Charlie said this, it is weird that we spend more time learning about Oscar's dog in a ladle than Jim and Pam's baby. I can't remember what the thinking was, but being a second child myself, I can attest to the fact that we just don't get
所以我问了查理·格兰迪关于这事。他是这一集的导演，但他也是资深编剧。查理是这么说的，奇怪的是，我们花在了解奥斯卡汤勺里的小狗身上的时间，居然比吉姆和帕姆的孩子还要多。我不记得当时是怎么想的，但作为一个二胎，我可以作证的事实是，我们确实没有得到
the same amount of attention. All we can hope is that a second child myself, I can attest to the fact that we just don't get the same amount of attention. All we can hope is that the second child of theirs is now 12 and turning toward comedy as a desperate way to finally be seen. You know, there was also an Aaron talking head that would have followed this scene. That is absolutely delicious. I saw it in the shooting draft. She is really struggling with the fact that they were freezing Susan out of this conversation. And here's what she would have said.
那么多的关注。我们只能希望他们的第二个孩子现在12岁了，正转向喜剧，作为最终被关注的绝望方式。你知道的，在这个场景之后原本还有一个艾伦的单人访谈。那绝对是太精彩了。我在拍摄剧本里看到过。她真的很纠结于他们把苏珊排除在这个对话之外的事实。以下是她当时会说的话。
It made me laugh. You don't keep a puppy picture from a nice lady. I feel sick. And it was that type of ladle. There you go. I just like it that you don't keep a puppy picture from a nice lady. Yeah. I think the whole office was struggling because they liked her.
这让我笑出来。你不能对一位好心的女士隐瞒小狗的照片。我觉得恶心。就是那种汤勺。就是这样。我只是觉得你不能对一位好心的女士隐瞒小狗的照片。是的。我觉得整个办公室都在挣扎，因为他们挺喜欢她的。
Andy had a talking head that was in the shooting draft that didn't make it where he said, please, please, just somebody piss off the nice lady. Yes, exactly. Well, Susan's gonna have a talking head where she says, you know what, I get it. The last time I had a job, I hated the boss's wife too. Of course, she was married to Robert. Wow. Wow. Susan, a little scandalous. Now, she's going to go confide to her husband. That she doesn't
安迪在拍摄剧本中有一个未被采用的单人访谈，他说，求求你们，随便谁去惹恼这位好女士吧。是的，完全如此。好吧，苏珊将有一个单人访谈，她说，你知道吗，我懂。我上次工作时，我也讨厌老板娘。当然，她当时嫁的是罗伯特。哇。哇。苏珊，有点八卦。现在，她要向她的丈夫倾诉，
think anyone here really likes her. He's like, we will do something about this right away. Again, Robert, you're overselling. You're overselling this. He's like, Andy, get in here. And then he excuses himself. He's like, not going to stick around for the conversation. Andy fix it. And Susan is going to get Andy to reveal that maybe, maybe there's something more going on here. Andy is no match for Susan. No. She is just watching him and observing quietly and figuring it all out. And Andy cannot hide his truth. We're going to get our first glimpse now of Dwight's newfangled gym with all the real equipment. His gym for muscles is really nice.
她觉得这里没有人真正喜欢她。罗伯特说，我们马上会为此采取行动。再说一次，罗伯特，你反应过头了。你反应过头了。他说，安迪，滚进来。然后他借口走开了。他说，我可不在这儿掺和这对话。安迪，搞定它。而苏珊将让安迪透露，也许，也许这里面还有更多内情。安迪根本不是苏珊的对手。不。她只是看着他，静静地观察并把一切都弄明白了。而安迪无法掩盖真相。现在我们要首次窥见德怀特装备齐全的新式健身房了。他的肌肉健身房真的很棒。
I remember this gym. At one point, I remember the writers got a treadmill. I remember that. It was in their writer's trailer, and I would go in there, and I would walk on that treadmill. Me too. The treadmill that you see in Dwight's Gym is the one they took it from the writer's trailer.
我记得这个健身房。有一次，我记得编剧们弄了一台跑步机。我记得那个。它在他们的编剧房车里，我会去那里，在那台跑步机上走路。我也是。你在德怀特健身房看到的跑步机就是他们从编剧房车里拿过去的那个。
Steve Burgess said, yeah, that was the writer's trailer, treadmill, and after this episode, we got to keep almost all of that equipment, and we finally had a gym. Dwight's gym for muscles became the cast and crew gym. Finally, after eight years. I never used it single time. Did you ever use it? Yes. I used to walk on the treadmill all the time. No, I walked on the treadmill, but all the weights and all that stuff. I used the weights. You did. I did. Yeah, because I do
史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，对，那是编剧房车的跑步机，在这集之后，我们得到了几乎所有这些器材，我们终于有了一个健身房。德怀特的肌肉健身房成了演员和剧组的健身房。八年了，终于有了。我一次都没用过。你用过吗？用过。我以前经常在跑步机上走路。不，我在跑步机上走过，但所有那些哑铃和重物什么的。我用过重物。你用过。我用过。对，因为我确实
like weights. Yeah, I didn't do any of that. I did love Dwight trying to motivate Darryl to work out. And Darryl was like, I was just on the treadmill for 35 minutes. And Dwight goes, no, you weren't. I timed it. It was eight minutes. And that rang so true to me. Because I feel like I get on the treadmill for five minutes.
喜欢重物。对，我什么都没做。我确实很喜欢德怀特试图激励达里尔锻炼。而达里尔说，我刚在跑步机上跑了35分钟。德怀特说，不，你没有。我计时了。只有8分钟。这让我觉得太真实了。因为我觉得我在跑步机上呆了5分钟，
I'm like, oh, I have. I've been here forever. Yeah. I really wish podcasts were around back then because I feel like I would have worked out so much more if I could have listened to a podcast. I used to have playlists. Yeah.
我就想，哦，我。我已经在这儿呆了半天了。是的。我真的很希望当年就有播客，因为我觉得如果能听着播客，我肯定会多锻炼很多。我以前有播放列表。是的。
Oh my gosh, do you think anyone is working out right now? Are we keeping you company on a treadmill somewhere? If you are working out right now, you can do it. You got it. Keep going. Yes, and in the words of Dwight from this episode, bring that same buffalo-wing passion to this gym. You can do it.
噢天哪，你觉得现在有人在锻炼吗？我们在跑步机某处陪着你吗？如果你现在正在锻炼，你能行的。你行的。坚持下去。是的，用本集中德怀特的话来说，把那种对鸡翅的热情带到这个健身房来。你行的。
That's right. You're getting healthy. Way to go. Let's go a little pep talk. That's pep talk. All right. Well, Robert is gonna return and he finds Andy and Susan still in the conference room and Susan's gonna say,
没错。你要变得健康了。干得好。来个小鼓舞士气。那是鼓舞士气。好吧。罗伯特回来了，他发现安迪和苏珊还在会议室里，苏珊说，
hey, you know what? Turns out I'm not gonna be working here after all. And then she basically says, you know what? Andy kind of let me in on it. I'm up to speed and Robert's like, what are you talking about? You know? And Andy says, hey, I don't want to get caught in the middle of this marital issue. And Robert's like, Andy, be honest, okay? Whatever you're trying to do right now, Andy, whatever this privacy thing is you're trying to do, we don't need it, just be honest. No games.
嘿，你知道吗？原来我还是不在这儿工作了。然后她基本上说，你知道吗？安迪算是向我透底了。我都了解清楚了。罗伯特说，你在说什么呢？你知道吗？安迪说，嘿，我可不想夹在这桩婚姻问题中间。罗伯特说，安迪，老实说，好吗？不管你现在想搞什么名堂，安迪，不管你搞什么保密把戏，我们不需要这个，老实说。别玩游戏。
And Andy's like, no games, no games, be honest. So Andy's like, okay, here's everything that happened. He came running, Andy banged on the window. He said, don't give her a job. Blah, blah, blah. And Robert's like, you son of a bitch, you liar. You are a liar. Say you're lying.
安迪说，不玩游戏，不玩游戏，老实说。所以安迪说，好吧，事情是这样的。他跑着来的，安迪拍打着窗户。他说，别给她工作。巴拉巴拉。罗伯特说，你个混蛋，你撒谎。你是个骗子。说你在撒谎。
So Andy's like, listen, the person who knows everything who was there when it happened is Jim. Jim knows the whole truth. Well, Jim hears this and he has to get out of dodge. It made me laugh when Robert goes, wait, where's Jim and Aaron goes? He, he, I'm like crawled out, he like rolled and then crawled and scooged.
所以安迪说，听着，知道所有内情、当时在场的人是吉姆。吉姆知道全部真相。好吧，吉姆听到这话，他必须赶快溜之大吉。罗伯特问，等等，吉姆呢？艾伦说，他，他，我像爬出去一样，他翻滚着然后爬着溜走了，这让我笑出声。
So Charlie Grandy said that they really needed something new for this storyline to happen in Act Three. So they came up with this storyline of Jim needing to escape. They thought it would be a really great way to inject some kind of silly physical comedy into the script and also relieve some of the tension. Yeah. Because now they're going to have to go as a group and find Jim. I loved when he dropped his shoe as he was climbing up the side of the building and he goes, ow, ow, ow. Because you know that little metal bar
所以查理·格兰迪说，在第三幕中，他们真的很需要一些新鲜的东西来推动这个剧情。所以他们想出了吉姆需要逃跑这个情节。他们认为这是一种将某种滑稽的肢体喜剧注入剧本的绝佳方式，同时也缓解了一些紧张气氛。是的。因为现在他们必须成群结队去找吉姆。我喜欢他在爬大楼外墙时掉了一只鞋，然后说，哎哟，哎哟，哎哟。因为你知道那根小金属条
on your barefoot climbing what hurt? Yes. We got a fan question from Maddie and Arkansas who said, did Jim really climb that ladder to the top of the building? It feels like a major stunt that would definitely require a safety meeting. Also, how did they make his shoe fall off just right?
在你赤脚攀爬时会多痛？是的。我们收到了来自阿肯色州马迪的粉丝提问，她说，吉姆真的爬那个梯子爬到大楼顶上了吗？感觉这是一个需要安全会议的重大特技。还有，他们是怎么把他的鞋子掉得刚刚好的？
Well, Charlie Grandy said that shooting gem on the ladder and then on the roof was absolutely nerve-wracking, especially on the ladder. And when he had to drop the shoe because he did not think that John was Harnestin. He does not look Harnestin. He looks like he's just climbing the ladder. Steve Birch has said that he thinks we did have a safety harness on John and we removed the wire in post. Well, let's stick with that story. And Steve said we did have several safety meetings about it. We had just changed stunt coordinators. Our new stunt coordinator was Brett Jones starting with this episode. And the whole shoe thing was just John.
好吧，查理·格兰迪说，拍摄吉姆爬梯子然后在屋顶上的戏绝对是令人神经紧绷的，特别是爬梯子的时候。当他不得不掉鞋子的时候，因为他不认为约翰绑了安全绳。他看起来确实没绑安全绳。他看起来就像是在单纯地爬梯子。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说他觉得我们确实给约翰系了安全绳，然后在后期去掉了威亚。好吧，我们就按这个说法吧。史蒂夫说我们确实为此开了好几次安全会议。我们刚换了特技协调员。从这一集开始，我们的新特技协调员是布雷特·琼斯。整个掉鞋子的事情完全是约翰的即兴发挥。
He just kicked it off and it was perfect and we only had to do one take. He said John was completely safe the whole time. It just looked a lot more dangerous than it really was. Okay. Okay. Okay. Well, you know, when Jim gets to the roof, Cree just up there. Yeah, he's flying a some helicopter. We had a fan question from Brent D in Virginia.
他只是把它踢飞了，而且非常完美，我们只拍了一条。他说约翰全程都非常安全。只是看起来比实际危险得多。好吧。好吧。好吧。当吉姆到达屋顶时，克里德居然在那里。是的，他在开直升机。我们收到了来自弗吉尼亚州布伦特D的粉丝提问。
In a episode from three years earlier, Cree was shown shopping for a helicopter on his work he sees. He had blackmailed his co-workers for the funds, and supposedly he was going to quote, fly it down to Brazil, down to the Amazon, in search of the world's largest bookstore. Brett said on its own and without any prior setup, Creed's rooftop pastime just seems like another one of his many quirky eccentricities. Was that the intent or was this a callback on the writer's part? Brett, this was an amazing callback. And I love that you spotted it.
在三年前的一集中，克里德曾在他的工作电脑上被拍到在选购一架直升机。他勒索同事筹集资金，据说他打算，引号，把它开到巴西，开到亚马逊，去寻找世界上最大的书店。布伦特说，就凭它本身，在没有任何先前铺垫的情况下，克里德在屋顶上的消遣看起来就像是他众多古怪个性中的又一个。这是剧本的本意，还是编剧的一个彩蛋？布伦特，这是一个了不起的彩蛋。我很高兴你发现了它。
Yeah. Great catch. I guess Dwight's a personal trainer now. Apparently he's going to show you how to do a pelvic bowl. Daryl's not into it, but Gabe, right away, it's like, hey, nice pelvic bowl. Mm-hmm. So like I said, the gym storyline is a lot bigger. Here are the office co-workers that join Dwight's gym
是的。抓得太准了。我猜德怀特现在是个私人教练了。显然他要教你做骨盆倾斜。达里尔对此不感兴趣，但盖布立刻就说，嘿，不错的骨盆倾斜。嗯哼。就像我说的，健身房的故事线要大得多。以下是加入德怀特肌肉健身房的办公室同事
for muscles. In addition to Daryl, Kathy, Aaron, Oscar, Gabe, and Meredith all join. And you see them working out. Oh, yeah, there's some really funny scenes. And as it turns out, you know, we find out why Darryl wants to be at the gym. He finally admits he wants to look good for Val.
除了达里尔，卡西、艾伦、奥斯卡、盖布和梅雷迪思都加入了。你会看到他们在锻炼。哦，是的，有一些非常有趣的场景。结果证明，你知道的，我们发现为什么达里尔想去健身房了。他终于承认他想在瓦尔面前显得帅一点。
Yes, of course Dwight thinks this is Val Kilmer. Mm-hmm. Well, you know, we had a really great fan catch from Jenny B and Ontario Canada who says, is it just me or is Gabe running backwards on the elliptical machine? Yes, he is. Jenny B, an Ontario Canada who says, is it just me or is Gabe writing backwards on the elliptical machine? Yes, he is.
是的，当然德怀特以为这是瓦尔·基尔默。嗯哼。好吧，你知道的，我们收到了来自加拿大安大略省珍妮B的一个非常棒的粉丝捕捉，她说，是我一个人觉得还是盖布在椭圆机上倒着跑？是的，他是。加拿大安大略省的珍妮B说，是我一个人觉得还是盖布在椭圆机上倒着踩？是的，他是。
I looked at his feet and he's going in the reverse order. He's not going forward, he's going backwards. Well, Susan and Robert's storyline is gonna wrap up back in the conference room. They're now in there with Andy and Jim and Susan very pointedly says to Jim, is this all true? Does Robert not want me to work here?
我看了一下他的脚，他在反方向运动。他不是向前，他在向后。好吧，苏珊和罗伯特的故事线将在会议室里收尾。他们现在和安迪、吉姆一起在里面，苏珊直截了当地对吉姆说，这一切都是真的吗？罗伯特是不是不想让我在这里工作？
Answer the question. And Jim kind of gives a long speech about how he works with his wife and he loves working with his wife. And he wishes she were here. And the more he talks, the more apparent it is, how true that is for Jim, and how untrue it is for Robert.
回答这个问题。吉姆长篇大论了一番，讲述了他和妻子一起工作，他喜欢和妻子一起工作。他希望她也在这里。他讲得越多，这种真情实感对吉姆而言有多真实，对罗伯特而言有多虚假，就越明显。
Yes. We don't see exactly how Robert and Susan are going to resolve this within their marriage, but it is clear that Susan is not going to work there and she goes down to the parking lot with Andy. And then she sort of hits on him. That's sort of, to me, it implied that she doesn't think things with Robert and they're working out
是的。我们没有看到罗伯特和苏珊将如何在婚姻中解决这个问题，但很显然苏珊不会在那里工作了，她和安迪一起去了停车场。然后她有点调戏了他。在我看来，这暗示着她觉得她和罗伯特的事没戏了，
because she says when all of this settles down, it's a date. Yeah. We really hit it off, I think. Yeah. Fan mail flurry. I bet. People wanted to know, was there any plan to continue the Andy Mrs. California storyline? Well, Charlie Grandy said he thinks there was, but he's not really sure what happened to that arc because he had to leave the office immediately after shooting this episode. He said that while we were shooting the act to conference room scene with Andy Susan
因为她说等这一切平息下来后，我们约会吧。是的。我觉得我们俩真挺合得来的。是的。粉丝来信雪片般飞来。我敢打赌。大家想知道，有没有计划继续安迪和加利福尼亚太太的故事线？好吧，查理·格兰迪说他觉得原本是有的，但他不太确定那个故事线后来怎么了，因为他在拍完这一集后不得不立刻离开办公室。他说，在我们拍摄第二幕安迪、苏珊
and Robert, he got a phone call and he learned that a pilot he had written was going to get made like next week and he had to leave the show. So he was really bummed, but he was also super happy that he got to direct this episode before he left. Wow. But he's not sure. He said, yes, there were some plans
和罗伯特的会议室场景时，他接到一个电话，得知他写的一个试播集下周就要投拍了，他不得不离开剧组。所以他感到很遗憾，但也超级高兴在离开前能导演这一集。哇。但他不确定。他说，是的，确实有一些计划
to maybe keep more in the mix. Yeah, I can't remember what happened. I sort of remember that scotle, but we all loved working with her. And she was so great in the episode. And I remember after this episode aired, everyone being like, ooooh. So I'm sad we didn't get to see a date between those two. Well, Andy has been seeing someone now for 31 dates. Yeah. We never meet that person, either. Nope. Well, that is Mrs. California, everybody. A big thank you to Steve Burgess and
也许会让更多角色保留在剧情中。是的，我不记得发生了什么。我隐约记得那个斯科特学费梗，但我们都很喜欢和她合作。她在这一集里表现得太棒了。我记得这一集播出后，所有人都发出“噢～～”的声音。所以我很遗憾没能看到那两人的约会。好吧，安迪现在已经和某个人约会31次了。是的。我们从来没见过那个人。没有。好吧，以上就是加利福尼亚太太的故事，各位。非常感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯、
Charlie Grandy and all of you for sending in your questions. Seriously, your questions are so good. Your background catches are amazing. I feel like we dig into the episode and then you guys will write in and say something and I'm like, oh my gosh. I know, so good.
查理·格兰迪以及所有发来问题的朋友。说真的，你们的问题太棒了。你们对背景细节的捕捉太惊人了。我觉得我们深入探讨了这一集，然后你们写信说了一些内容，让我直呼噢天哪。我知道，太棒了。
It's really a team effort. It really is. We love you guys. And if you're on a treadmill right now, it's been more than eight minutes! You did it! You did it! You did it! Way to go! We'll see you next week!
这真的是团队合作。确实如此。我们爱你们。如果你现在正在跑步机上，已经超过8分钟了！你做到了！你做到了！你做到了！干得漂亮！我们下周见！
Bye! [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keifer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley
拜拜！[♪ 片尾曲播放 [♪ 感谢收听办公室女郎。办公室女郎由 Earwolf、珍妮弗·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·凯弗。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的副制作人工是艾恩斯利
Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad free versions of office ladies, go to stitur premium.com. For a free one month trial of stitupremium, use code office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
巴巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉特恩创作的《橡胶树》。想要无广告版的办公室女郎，请访问 stitcherpremium.com。如需免费试用 stitcherpremium 一个月，请使用优惠码 office。本集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。